A little pause... and we are back.
夜空は星が降るようで 夜空は星が降るようで いつからだろう 君のことを いつからだろう 君のことを
追いかける私がいた 届けない 驚かないで 届けない 驚かないで
聞いてよ 私の 聞いてよ 私の A little
pause...
and we are back.
A little pause... and we are back.
A little pause...
and we are back.
This is what it's like to fall in love, isn't it?
Go
to the bottom of your heart Listen to the voice of your heart The truth next to you is cruel I didn't say it, I couldn't say it I'll never say it again I can't forget that summer day The twinkling stars I can still remember them now Your smiling face and your angry face I loved them all It's strange,
isn't it?
I knew it, but...
you didn't know I was your secret Beyond the night In our distant memory you take my finger In your innocent voice A little
pause...
and we are back.